in the past few billion years Earth has
been pummeled by asteroids crashed into
other planets and frozen over several
times
not to mention being ruled by all kinds
of crazy life forms
sometimes it's a wonder that our blue
Homeworld has survived at all
but if we want to take a whirlwind tour
of our planet's history we'll have to
start way back at the very beginning
some four and a half billion years ago
our solar system began to emerge out of
a dense cloud of interstellar gas and
dust This Cloud collapsed into a
swirling disc of matter that got hotter
and hotter and hotter until hydrogen
fused into helium
and just like that our son was born
and baby Earth was on its way too
after the birth of our star all the
matter on the farthest ends of the
spinning disc began to Clump together
these clumps would be the seedlings for
the planets and moons in our solar
system as they accumulated more matter
they grew bigger and more spherical the
clumps in the cooler regions of the
solar system were mostly made of ice
liquids and gases
closer to the Sun all the rocky material
formed the inner planets like Mars and
Earth
this young Earth was incredibly active
volcanically speaking it spewed out
gases like hydrogen sulfide methane and
carbon dioxide
these gases made up the very first
atmosphere on our planet
early Earth was constantly bombarded by
large asteroids and comets and soon
Earth experienced an even more violent
Collision
Thea a planet the size of Mars slammed
right into our young world
this epic Collision threw chunks of
matter all around Earth's orbit and then
gravity bound them together into what we
know now as the Moon
[Music]
on this hot early Earth there were no
oceans
all water existed as gas
but 3.8 billion years ago our planet
cooled enough for water to condensate
and become liquid
the very first primitive ocean covered
this young Earth and turned it into a
water world
H2O is an essential ingredient for
creating living things so with all that
water life appeared on Earth about 3.7
billion years ago
these earliest forms of life were
microscopic organisms but it was nearly
a billion years after that that some of
these organisms changed the course of
the world
[Music]
Earth didn't stay as a water world very
long
soon the very first continents emerged
from the ancient ocean
scientists call them cratons
as more and more land Rose from the
ocean the very first supercontinent
appeared on the planet valbara wasn't
exactly a supercontinent it was pretty
small
scientists think it was smaller than the
continent of Australia
[Music]
around 2.4 billion years ago
cyanobacteria evolved to become our
planet's first photosynthesizers
finally we had some oxygen producers to
make Earth's atmosphere much more
hospitable
and the rest is history folks
just kidding we've still got a long way
to go
with all this new oxygen Earth's
atmosphere had much lower levels of
carbon dioxide and that made the planet
icy cold
much of our Young World froze over as
Earth saw its first ice age
now as Earth's atmosphere was changing
the continents were moving too
they broke up and reassembled into the
next supercontinent rodinia
rodinia was a real supercontinent it may
have been the largest supercontinence to
ever cover the planet
and life
well life finally became more complex
but then something happened
rodinia broke apart and a new
supercontinent assembled
this one was called panosia
then between about 540 and 485 million
years ago there was an explosion of New
Life
this time was called the Cambrian
explosion and the animals that evolved
during this period had hard body parts
like shells or spines
the most famous of all were the alien
looking trilobites
[Music]
around 440 million years ago the climate
suddenly shifted and the temperature of
the ocean changed dramatically
Earth saw its first mass extinction
event
this was the ordovision silurian
extinction and a majority of the life
that had been spreading around the
planet vanished
many of these life forms laid the
foundation for the ecosystems that we
have on Earth today
somewhere between 420 to 350 million
years ago the first trees arose from
Earth's soil
and the first animals made their way to
land too
[Music]
250 million years ago the planet was
covered by Our Last vast supercontinent
Pangea
sadly it was also during this period
that Earth witnessed the greatest mass
extinction event in our history the
great dying
huge amounts of greenhouse gases and
accelerated global warming wiped out
about 90 percent of all species on Earth
but this mass extinction helped pave the
way for the next wave of animals to
evolve
240 to 230 million years ago the first
dinosaurs appeared for the next
150 million years they'd rule the land
if you were there you'd have witnessed
the gigantic sauropod Argentinosaurus
the largest land animal ever
or you might have been chased by one of
the earth's greatest apex predators the
T-Rex
and you'd also witnessed Pangea breaking
up and forming the continents we know
today
okay you may already know where this is
headed
six million years ago an asteroid
slammed into our planet right where
Mexico sits now and it coughed up so
much debris into the atmosphere that it
blocked out the Sun
this led to devastating climate changes
that caused the dinosaurs to die out
in the next wave of emerging animals
mammals became more common
[Music]
around 6 million years ago the earliest
known humans started walking this world
it's called sahalanthropus
though they still likely walked on all
fours
four million years ago early humans
began to walk upright and about 1
million years later they developed the
first known tools which they used to
break things some eight hundred thousand
years ago things sparked these early
humans discovered how to control fire
and could now cook food and provide
themselves with heat their brains
continued to evolve now more rapidly
than ever
these humans learned to interact with
each other and the surrounding World in
whole new ways
then between forty thousand to fifteen
thousand years ago all other human
species besides Homo sapiens went
extinct
ten thousand years ago Earth saw its
earliest farmers
these previously nomadic humans stopped
wandering the planet and finally put
down their roots
jumping way forward to about 250 years
ago the Industrial Revolution took place
we went through major technological
socioeconomic and cultural
transformations
rural-based Farm societies became more
industrialized Urban ones
our human population continued to grow
by 1804 we reached 1 billion by 1927
we'd hit 2 billion
and since the 1960s the global
population has risen faster and faster
to where it is now at over 8 billion
people
and now there's a new threat to human
existence and many other forms of life
here on Earth
climate change
temperatures and sea levels are rising
worldwide and biodiversity is declining
we could be on the verge of another mass
extinction event if things don't change
but that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
foreign